solid a declarative javascript framework
for building fast uis with maximum
control over reactivity it was created
by ryan carniato in 2018 and is loved by
developers because it's both pragmatic
and extremely performant on the surface
it shares many similarities with react
components are javascript functions that
return jsx for the ui however unlike
react there's no virtual dom it uses a
compiler more like svelt that converts
your code into vanilla javascript to
bring you as close to the dom as
possible the framework itself only
weighs 7 kilobytes and it completely
crushes runtime performance benchmarks
without the need for any extra magic or
weird hacks in your code but most
importantly it's truly reactive a
function component is only called once
which means you can do unheard of things
like you set interval predictably at the
top level data that changes or state is
managed with the create signal primitive
which returns a getter and setter the
framework will observe this data and
surgically update its exact location in
the dom when it changes instead of
re-rendering the entire component again
it's truly reactive to get started
generate a new solid project it uses
veet as the build tool and should look
very familiar if you've ever used react
define a component as a plain javascript
function now when you define the ui with
jsx you actually get a real dom element
instead of some weird framework
abstraction to add reactive state to a
component use the create signal function
it provides a getter and setter and
notice how the getter is a function this
allows the framework to observe the
current value reactively we can easily
create derived state by simply defining
another function based on the original
signal and it also provides a function
to memoize the return value or expensive
computations in some cases you may want
to run code when your data changes for
that createfact allows you to run side
effects any signals referenced in the
body of the function will automatically
be subscribed to to rerun the side
effect whenever the value changes solid
also provides on mount and on cleanup
functions that tap into the beginning
and end of the component lifecycle the
framework also goes out of its way to
make jsx more developer friendly for
example it has a show component to
handle conditional logic and the four
component to simplify loops over a
collection of items when it comes to
collections it also provides a create
store function that can easily handle
nested reactivity and it supports custom
directives with a used keyword which is
a highly efficient way to attach custom
behaviors to different elements and it
has everything else you would expect in
a modern framework like lazy loading
context ssr support and so on this has
been solid in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one